he said Loki the attack on New York
that's him
Iron Man fought with all of his heart
against Thanos and literally brought out
all of the big guns it's not a metaphor
guys go grab some big guns but in the
end it still wasn't enough to stop daños
and prevent the snapping if you'd like
to enter my giveaway for a chance to win
a copy of infinity war Deadpool 2 or
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as well
as some special edition posters all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero out of all the Avengers that
were left after the snap Tony is the one
that took this defeat the most
personally Tony had been preparing for
this moment this attack from Thanos
since the events of the first Avengers
movie Pony is the one in the first
Avengers movie who flew the nuke into
space and is the only Avenger that saw
the full extent of Thanos his army
anybody remember when I carried a nuke
through a wormhole no it's never come
save New York never heard that recall
that worthy Avengers we can bust arms
dealers all the live long day but that
up there that's that's the in-game we
learned from Iron Man 3 that this
severely scarred Tony and gave him very
extreme PTSD because he knew that this
army would one day come back and attack
and from that moment he began to prepare
for an imminent attack from Thanos
from this moment Tony began to prepare
for this attack in many different ways
Tony actually designed Ultron to be a
defence against Thanos his army when it
came but we all know how that worked out
then after the events of age of Ultron
Tony then began to focus on his
technology and his Ironman armor we then
learned from the Avengers infinity war
prelude comics that Tony has been
focusing on what he calls the real
threat and the end of all things of
course referring to Thanos and his army
and of course after the events of Civil
War and him and Captain America broke up
as he says an infinity war Tony decides
that is going to be up to him alone to
prepare for this attack and of course
his preparation
was the nanotech armored we see his
design for the mark 50 in the comic as
well as the iron spider suit so to Tony
the mark 50 nanotech suit was his
ultimate defense against Stannis when he
came Tony
the ability for the nanoparticles to
form whatever weapon Tony thought of was
enough to defeat Thanos but it obviously
wasn't and here's the thing about the
nanotech suit it was the best Tony could
do Tony can't create anything better
than his mark 50 nanotech suit we
learned this from Joe Russo himself Joe
Russo said that the journey that Tony's
been on as a genius scientist is that
the evolution of his armor this is the
best it's ever gonna get for Tony and it
still is not enough to beat Thanos in
fact it barely keeps him in the fight so
this is basically Joe Russo saying that
this is Tony at his very best and he
barely put up a fight against Thanos in
fact I don't think Danis was actually
trying that hard and now Tony knows this
he knows that he can't defeat Thanos at
least in his current state this is most
likely why Avengers 4 is rumored to take
place five years into the future Tony
needs time to work on his suits
he knows that right after the snap he
can't do anything against Thanos he just
got his butt kicked
he needs to upgrade and enhance his
suits he needs to go further along in
his technology development and this is
also probably why time travel comes into
play in Avengers 4 he knows he can't
defeat Thanos currently so he has to go
back in time and either stop Thanos from
getting all the Infinity stones or
collect Infinity stones himself either
way Tony knows that he cannot defeat
Thanos in the present time right now he
just gave him his very best and it did
nothing so Tony's gonna have to figure
out another way to defeat Thanos and
Avengers 4 so let me know what you think
Tony's going to do to further prepare
himself to take on Thanos in Avengers 4
let me know your thoughts and theories
in the comments below and don't forget
to subscribe comment and like the video
so you can enter the giveaway and stay
up to date on everything related to
Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you